This country must be somewhat unfamiliar to you because the Sultanate of Oman,...
...the land of frankincense, has been quite obscure and closed off until now.
However, it is becoming one of the fastest growing tourist destinations in the world.
Unlike the rest of the Gulf, Oman's southern city of Salalah...
...offers an unexpected and pleasant 80 degrees and lush greenery during the summer months.
If you don't want to bear the sticky, humid summer in your country,...
...you should think about spending your summer vacation in Salalah.
There, you would feel as if you are in a green, fresh garden during the summer.
You can fully enjoy the natural phenomenon of rain-bearing fog known as the Khareef season.
While you enjoy the freshness, there are a variety of things to do.